hi christian yeah we're here at the
galleria mall one of the busiest places
across the county to cast your ballot
doors open here at 6 45 there were
people waiting and then there was a
steady stream of people since about 9 30
this morning and it hasn't let up since
then i want to show you where the line
is right now over my shoulder that's
where the line starts we counted
anywhere from about 80 to 100 people
over the last five minutes waiting in
line chatted with them they're waiting
about 25 to 30 minutes to cast their
ballot and if you plan to head out here
we want to tell you where the best place
to park and enter the galleria mall is
you want to enter either the main
entrance by the restaurant or the other
side by kohl's
i've been doing this for 20 years it's
part of my civic duty i think nadine
singleton has assisted with clark
county's voting process over the past
two decades she's been banning this
location at galleria mall since early
voting began two weeks ago the last day
was i mean it was the best turnout ever
and i mean it was really exciting
because we all felt energized
this morning it was a little slow but
once the mall opened
as you can see the lines are out the
door she says things have been moving
smoothly and people are honored to come
out and vote in person we caught up with
a number of people at this location to
find out what brought them out on
primary day they represented a mix of
political views with concerns about
state and national issues i'm looking
really at issues of climate change
women's health care
gun control all of the really hot topic
we've got so many price things going on
right now and
and even just it seems like we're
disconnected and you go i want to i want
to do my part to try to make sure we're
connected as a country the governor and
lieutenant governor are very important
to a lot of people here we want to see
our state
back to where it's going to be we're
hoping in the right direction i came out
to vote for sam brown for senate
because i like his grassroots movements
i like his that he wants the parents to
take control of their
education for their children i have to
admit i am a trump fan so i'm going to
vote for his recommendations i'm 25 so i
feel like that's something that
people my age should be getting into and
younger because it's going to affect us
eventually so that's what brought me out
today
and polls do close at seven but if
you're online you will get to vote we do
want to let you this is a fun group of
poll workers when they come across a
first-time voter they all cheer and ring
a bell in celebration reporting live i'm
kirstjen joyce live local now